Speaker 1: Welcome everybody, I want to start
today with the worker strikes that have been
really spreading nationally across a variety
of different industries and types of jobs,
and I think it's very interesting what's going
on.
There's a couple of different perspectives
about why this is taking place if and why
this is the right time for these types of
strikes.
But the big picture for me is this is a good
thing without weighing in on the reasonableness
or the specifics of every strike.
Large employers are faced with the reality
that for whatever reason, you believe there
are so many open jobs and we're going to talk
about that in a moment that employees or potential
employees or former employees have what appears
to be some newfound leverage, which hopefully
they can use to their advantage.
So let's start first with a Washington Post
article.
Strikes are sweeping the labor market as workers
wield new leverage.
The labor activism runs the gamut of American
industry, powered by the same grievances about
wages, benefits and quality of life.
Driving the great resignation.
Let's look at a little more of this.
Americans are leaving their jobs at staggering
rates.
A record 4.3 million quit in August alone.
Hundreds of thousands of workers with similar
grievances about wages, benefits and quality
of life are choosing to dig in and fight.
Last week, 10000 John Deere workers went on
strike.
Unions representing 31000 Kaiser employees
authorized walkouts.
60000 Hollywood production workers reached
a deal Saturday night, averting a strike.
Hours before a negotiation deadline.
All told, there have been strikes against
178 employers this year, according to a tracker
by Cornell University's School of Industrial
and Labor Relations.
The Bureau of Labor Statistics, which records
only large work stoppages, has documented
12 strikes involving a thousand or more workers
so far this year.
That's higher than 2020, when the pandemic
took hold in line with strike activity from
2019 and from 2018 the trend.
Union officials and economists say, is an
offshoot of the phenomenon known as the great
resignation, which has thinned the nation's
labor pool and slowed economic recovery.
Workers are now harder to replace, especially
while many companies are scrambling to meet
heightened demand for products and manage
hobbled supply chains that has given unions
new leverage and made striking less risky.
This is a really important thing to understand.
The one story that is essentially being told
is the reason there are open jobs and the
reason why so many restaurants, for example,
are putting up signs saying, We've got no
employees, we've got to close.
Is lazy workers choosing to sit at home collecting
enhanced unemployment?
Now this is not only wrong, it's also incomplete
and it's also deceptive, first of all.
The enhanced unemployment is all but completely
gone and phased out.
So yes, there are people collecting unemployment.
The vast majority are collecting what is standard
in the state in which they in which they live.
And that varies.
And in some states, it's really not very much.
The second piece of this is that the child
care component is a particularly big factor
because of the concerns about COVID.
If you have kids that are too young to be
vaccinated, it's not just a financial consideration,
it's also what about my kids who can't be
vaccinated?
Do I want them in school or not or part time?
So the school piece is a big piece of this.
We also have this additional wrinkle, which
is anecdotally, I've had people write to me
and take this for what it is, which is just
an anecdote I'm being upfront about that people
have written to me and they've said, Listen,
David, my employer.
Claims to be hiring.
So when you hear about 100 unfilled positions,
a couple of people wrote to me from different
companies saying my employer has 20 positions
listed, 30 positions listed, 40 positions
listed.
We're not interviewing anybody for these positions.
And what these folks writing to me believe
is going on is that the companies are listing
jobs in order to placate the workers they
have who have been given the job of one and
a half people or two people, in some cases
during the pandemic, so that the workers believe
we're going to replace those folks who left
or who we laid off or whatever the case may
be.
We're hiring, but really, it's to keep the
existing employees doing the jobs of one and
a half or two people calm as they continue
to do way more work than they normally would,
because the company would say, Hey, we'd love
to just have one person doing a job we used
to need, you know, three people for two jobs
or two people for whatever the case may be.
So anecdotally, that's going on.
And then also, the leverage is coming from
the particularly acute need from a lot of
these companies to actually scale up logistics
companies, delivery companies, a lot of products.
There's a couple of products I'm waiting for
that are just heavily.
I don't buy a lot of stuff, but the couple
of things I'm actually trying to buy right
now.
I'm told it's going to be a couple of months
before we can even get them to you.
And that is giving employees and unions more
leverage than they would normally have.
So there's a lot of good here.
It's it's not good to have a supply chain
that doesn't feel like it's functioning properly
and to have an inability to access basic products,
that's not good.
That is less related to what we're talking
about here.
It's a good thing for labor and workers to
have a little bit more leverage disproportionately.
They tend not to have it.
There are a ton of so-called best jobs out
there right now, and a big part of that is
employee or employers first finding ways to
nickel and dime employees who are W-2 employees,
then shifting to a model of just putting people
as independent contractors to 199.
That's a big topic of controversy with Uber
and similar companies, and I've talked about
this before.
It it is.
I mean, listen, I don't think at this point
I could work for someone else.
I might be functionally unemployable at this
point if I had to go and apply for a job and
have a boss who gives me a schedule and monitors
breaks and all these different things.
I think that I've been working for myself
for so long at this point that I would not
even be able to.
I think it would be terrible.
And when I speak to friends who are mostly
in that position, most of the people I know
are not working for themselves.
It sounds absolutely terrible for a lot.
Not all of them.
A lot of them have good jobs, so anything
that can be done to regain some leverage is
great.
And it appears as though at least some of
these strikes are are helping do that now.
By the way, if you're striking but you didn't
vote for candidates, you could have voted
for either locally state federal president
who ran on higher minimum wage democratization
of the workplace, more benefits.
You should be examining that as well, because
in addition to striking, you could also be
voting for the changes that you want as well
as a boss.
I try to do all the things I can reasonably
do as a small employer.
We have, you know, we condense the production
of the show into four days.
There's no set schedules.
We have an open vacation policy.
We just make sure everybody's work is covered.
I split health insurance 50-50 with some employers
do more, some do less.
We're able to do 50 50.
We do retirement account contributions.
As a small employer, I'm trying to do what
I can.
Large employers are in dramatically different
situations.
I think what's going on is very interesting
and we'll see what results come from it.